It should come as no surprise that water and electronics don't mix.
But don't panic, your cell phone can be saved.
You will need...
...a plastic container with a lid,...
...a blow dryer, a towel,...
...and two silica gel packs.
Step 1: Remove your phone's battery.
Many circuits inside the phone will survive if they are not attached to a power source when wet.
Step 2: Consult the manual to remove your phone's SIM card,...
...which stores the phone's data and allows it to connect to your service provider.
SIM cards can survive water damage.
Step 3: Dab the phone, battery, and SIM card with a towel,...
...then set the last two items aside.
Step 4: With your blow dryer set on the low or the cool air blast, dry your phone,...
...getting as much water out of the unit as possible.
Step 5: Place your phone, battery, and SIM card in the plastic container with the silica gel packs.
These absorb moisture and can be found in packaging, craft stores or online.
Allow the container to sit sealed for three days.
If you don't have access to silica gel,...
...place your phone in front of the air conditioner.
The cool air can help dry out moisture.
Step 6: If your phone does not work after three days,...
...plug it into its charger without the battery.
If this works, you will need a new battery.
Step 7: Call up everyone to explain why you haven't returned calls in three days.
Did you know the first cell phone introduced in 1984 weighed two pounds,...
...offered a half hour of talk time per charging...
...and retailed for nearly $4,000?